I've decided to tell you my life story.
It all starts in Acapulco.
The show "Acapulco"
is a rags-to-riches story
about this kid in the streets of Acapulco
and how he got to be this billionaire.
Right now, I'm a pool boy.
But one day, I'm gonna own this place.
Wow, I love the confidence.
I felt that we needed a show
you can watch and go to sleep
with a smile on your face,
or solely for the soul.
That's "Acapulco."
During this second season,
all the characters are evolving.
Now that the characters are established,
we can really dive into
what those relationships are like.
And it expands the world we've set up.
We have a new love interest on the show.
Isabel. She has no idea
about the connection I had
with Maximo in Season 1.
Now that he's going back to his origins,
we're gonna see a different Maximo.
Back then he was another person.
He left, also, a lot of things pending.
Maximo.
Okay, that's the second time
I see you hiding from me today.
That's not what I was doing.
Season 2 has been
even more fun than Season 1
because we all know each other now.
We are more free to try new tones.
We play more with the rhythm
and pace of the scenes.
In thirty-six years
as a professional actress,
it is not common to find
this sensation that we have.
I like to believe that Las Colinas
is not a place or a destination.
It's a community.
The fact that we're shooting
here in Mexico, it's important to me.
I want the series to reflect
how beautiful it is,
and especially the people.